welcome everyone and thank you very much
for coming to my talk it's the last one
I know you're all tired learned a lot of
interesting things so hopefully mine is
going to be a good end for a real
exciting day so yeah my name is Miss
Donna I work at masa which is
berlin-based startup which is working on
open source software for conversational
AI and I have a background in
econometrics I worked as a data
scientist for a couple of years and then
I just fell in love with open source
projects and conversational AI more
specifically and I joined Raza and now I
work on developer education and building
browser open source community so yes all
exciting so I'm going to talk about how
you can build AI assistants that scale
using machine learning and also systems
that can go beyond sorry I didn't get
that and before I dive into the other
content I have ready I actually I'm
going to do all the specifics that need
to be covered so my goal today is to
show you how we can build your own
machine learning powered assistant using
open source tools only and the roadmap
for my workshop is going to be that I'm
going to explain a lot step by step how
development of a I assistant looks like
and everything that is under the hood
when it comes to open source tools that
I'm going to use and also every single
part will include coding and at the very
end I will leave some time for questions
but if you have some burning questions
throughout the talk just raise your hand
and I'm happy to answer any questions
you have and the set up so there are
quite a few ways how we can follow this
workshop one of them is to use the
Jupiter notebook that's where I'm going
to use and you can get them by following
this link at the top there are actually
three in Egypt there are no books I will
explain which one you should recommend
you to use and and so on once we get the
actual point of coding but if you don't
want to use your paternal books on your
local machine or if something doesn't
work you can use the Google collab as
well so all these links are also on PI
data proposal of my talk so please go
check it out and get them ready before
we dive in into the coding part great so
yeah I'm going to talk about
conversational AI and I think it's it's
really hard to surprise people with chat
BOTS and conversational AI these days
because probably every single one of you
already saw a child water or used one
but despite of all this hype and a lot
of attention from the industry and from
the research it's still quite an early
stage for this field and developers that
are building assistants they still use
quite limiting approaches which are
rule-based approaches or state machines
for building assistance and they forget
a few very important things what make an
assistant good and intelligent so one of
them is that AI assistant must be able
to generalize well on the different user
inputs because in different users as
well because there are so many different
ways how one person can say something
that has the same meaning but using
different words vocabulary structure of
the sentences so a good assistant must
be able to generalize on different types
of speech and also another important
piece about AI systems is that they must
be able to learn from additional
information that a user provides or even
better learn from its own mistakes so
just like in this vision visualization
here you can see that if a user provides
some additional details or correct
assistance
and the system must be able to pick up
those videos and learn so these are just
a few challenges that Raza is trying to
tackle and as a result Raza developed an
open-source software stack called raza
stack and it it consists of two Python
libraries first one is called rasa Nou
which is just like the name suggests is
a library for natural language
understanding so enabling your assistant
to understand what is the users input
and extracting important information
that helps an assistant to make more
specific answers and correct answers and
another piece is called rasa core which
is a machine learning driven dialog
management system which uses machine
learning and real conversational data to
predict how an assistant should respond
based on the state of the conversation
and also the context and those answers
they can be a lot of different things
they can be simple text responses or
voice responses or it can be something
more complicated like some kind of
back-end integrations like API calls or
getting there from the database or
basically the sky's the limit of what
you can do so
how an assistant looks like that is
built with browser core and Raza and
Alou is here it's a simplified
architecture so let's say we have a user
who asks what's the weather like
tomorrow and the first stage that this
message would go through is a connector
module so this is where you can use any
voice or messaging platform that you
prefer can be I don't know facebook
messenger slack telegram or your own
inbuilt custom built UI for for your
childhood
then once this message is picked up it's
sent to input module so called ears and
this is where Raza and Lulu model stands
and it crunches the input of the user
and extracts the meaning of the user
input as well as all the details that
are important for an assistant to
respond well and they are passed to
dialogue management so called brain and
this is where as a core model stands it
takes all the details from an Illumina
and previous conversations and it
predicts what response or what actions
should be executed at specific state of
the conversation and as I mentioned you
can use back-end integrations there and
then once an assistant has all the
details to make a response they are all
sent to output module so called mouth
which is responsible to generate a
response in a regular human language so
that a human could understand and do
something with this information here you
have a bunch of options what you can do
you can use nlg natural language
generation approaches or you can use UI
elements buttons for example or you can
use a very simple approaches simply
provide some possible responses how an
assistant could respond based on the
details that is extracted and then once
the response is generated it is sent
back to the connector module so that's
how a user gets the response so for
example it could be it will be sunny and
Fanta degrees it's the previous question
so why rather I think you probably know
some alternatives to that which are
hosted solutions for example you
probably heard of dialogue so Louis VI
so if you think so one of them is that
it runs locally it's really up to you
where you want to run your assistant you
can bind on your local machine you can
run it on the cloud you can run it on
your custom server he sits yeah you just
take it and use it wherever you want
another thing is that you own your data
and that's super important for kin
that work with sensitive data so it's
open source so your data and
conversations that users have with your
assistant never gets to rasa we didn't
see what is happening and what kind of
conversations your users have so it's
it's yeah you you own your data and you
are in charge who can see it who can use
it who can access it and the biggest
advantage of open source is that is
hackable and there are really no black
boxes and you can see everything you can
see all the code of the models you can
tune the models you can add your own
custom components replace models if you
are not happy with the ones that are
inbuilt feroz's so it's really a lot of
fun that you can have as a developer
with this framework so yeah it's a
decided the main advantages for using
rasa for your project so now at this
point I will go deeper into these two
components masa and aloo animal support
and explain what is happening where is
machine learning hidden and how it works
and what kind of models are being used
so I will start with the first stage of
development development which is natural
language understanding so the main idea
as I have mentioned is to enable an
assistant to understand what the user
means what they are asking so the goal
is to take unstructured user input in a
simple human language for example just
like I have an example here
I have a new address it's an online King
Street San Francisco and this probably
user wants to change on address to
something to this new address so the
goal is to extract structured details
from this input which an assistant can
understand and use in the later stages
and the structured data consists of two
components first one is called intent so
overall intention of user input what it
is about so for example for this
specific example
good intent label could be address
change and another component of the
structured data that is extracted is
called entity or it can be a bunch of
entities which are pieces of information
that are necessary for an assistant to
extract and understand and use to make
correct responses so for example here an
address
709 King Street San Francisco is a good
example of an entity it's something that
an assistant should extract and then use
to make an actual address change so how
it works the main idea is that we use
word vectors so hopefully you know what
word vectors are and also an important
thing here as well is that it's just one
other way so how we can do it so if you
have a new user input for example what's
the weather like tomorrow the overall
process is that it goes through that
conversation stage we look up word
vectors for words and the create
sentence representation which is used to
build a classifier and this classifier
gives output in a following format where
you get the label of the intent like
what was the invention of a user input
more specifically bag of force on your
bestfriends here so let's say you have a
new in new user input what's the weather
like tomorrow the first stage that this
input goes through is tokenization so a
token can be word of a sentence and then
for each word the model would look up a
word vector here you also have a choice
of glove vectors or fast text is also a
good choice for preteen world factors if
you want to use them and then the next
stage is creating the sentence
representation here you can see we take
the average it's really simple it
surprisingly works really well
and
is being used to train the classifier in
this case it's a support vector machine
pretty simple classifier that gives the
results in a following way so if you
have in your training data five for
example possible intense that you wanted
your assistant to understand the result
of SVM will be one of those labels that
is the most probable that the model
thinks then the next stage and the
thinks extraction is quite similar
process but there are just a few
additional steps so it still it's all
based on vectors so whenever there is a
new user input again the sentence is
tokenized in two words also you can use
in a part of speech tagger and use that
as a feature for the model so you would
use grammatical meaning of the word is a
verb adjective noun and stuff like that
another feature that can be added to the
model are chunks so chunker creates just
like the name suggests chunks of words
from a sentence and why it's useful
because some entities for example
addresses it consists of more than one
word it's like it's usually at least
three or four or four or even more words
in a sentence so it's important to build
models that can extract one word
entities to word entities and so on and
this is what Shankar comes in to help
out and then this and other features are
being used to create a named entity
recognition model and the result of this
model is as follows so you would have
the label of the entity as well as the
value of the entity so for example in
this specific example about whether the
entity is date and the value of the
entity is tomorrow and other user inputs
for example if a user asked what's the
weather like today the entity would be
date again but the value would be today
so how that works there are a few
approaches for this problem one of them
you can build one classifier to first
classify if there is an entity in a
sentence or not in the first place and
then use another classifier to predict
the label of this entity but it's
time-consuming and also quite resource
heavy so the way it works at razza is
called direct structured prediction so
basically those two problems are tackled
at once and the algorithm that is being
used at razza here is called conditional
random fields so it's it works in a very
similar way as a skip gram model which
uses surrounding words and a sentence to
predict the label of the target word so
using preaching world actors works
really well especially if you have
limited amount of data and why it helps
because by using preaching block vectors
you don't need to learn where the
beddings yourself and also because it
allows your model to learn semantic
meaning of the words and relationships
between the words but it also brings
some limitations so using a classifier
type of approach you are only able to
assign one label for user input as in
with what is the intent of the user
input
however while we as humans are
complicated and our speech is not that
simple and things are not that easy and
so many times when you speak to your
friends when you send your friends a
message you usually express more than
one meaning in a sentence or more than
one requests or questions in one
sentence so if you want to build
assistance that can handle and natural
conversations it's important to tackle
those type of challenges as well and
this is where rather did a lot of
research in the past few months and
built a new model called
tensorflow embedding model which is
capable of doing
what you see in an example here when a
user's input has more than one possible
meaning the model is able to assign too
intense or three intents for the same
input and that makes the conversations
more natural and the flow of the
conversation is a lot more human-like so
how it works is first of all what's
called the problem is called supervised
world factors which means that the model
learns word embeddings from scratch so
basically using the data that you
provide in your it that you have in a
training data set and this model is
inspired by a paper called star space
which is paper from face book research
they're doing really amazing job on that
and and so if you're interested to learn
more details definitely we'd read the
paper I will share my slides after the
talk so you will also get overlay links
as well and but the main idea of this
model is that instead of having a
classifier that assigns a label to the
user input it's a ranking method so you
have user input you have the intense and
you learn embeddings for both and then
the process is that you calculate the
similarity between user input
descendants and all of the intents here
you can use for cosine similarity and
then it's the matter of optimizing the
loss function and getting the most
probable infants based on the ranking
method yep
in bedding layer freak like that no so
the so here you don't use any pretty
important factors again it learns from
the data that you provide in your
training data set I will show you how
the data looks like but it you don't use
any more vectors out there from
Wikipedia or anything else cool and
actually that's a good time to dive into
some code and show you how things work
so what I'm going to use and so I told
you about how possible ways to follow
this workshop I'm going to use Jupiter
notebook but again it's up to you which
one you prefer using and if you are
using Jupiter as well you probably saw
that in the repository that I shared
there are three Jupiter notebook so I'm
kind of ready for full possible outcomes
of this workshop I'm a bit jet-lagged
and had too much coffee so who knows
what can happen so basically I'm going
to use rather PI data DC workshop
starter which means that some of the
bits in this Jupiter notebook are going
to be left out so I'm going to do things
here live but if you want to see all the
code completed and all the outputs you
can either choose workshop executed
which has all the cell's completed and
all the results printed out or you can
use workshop completed which have just
basically has all the code it's up to
you which one you choose and also there
are some other files here some of them
are just simply outputs of some of the
cells in the Jupiter I'm actually going
to use two of these files one of them is
called story Cindy another one is called
Andalou dot MD but I will show you where
it just basically took at some time in
this workshop so I'm going to use again
PI data workshop starters of any one is
following me do give it a try great so
in this exercise I'm going to show you
how to build an assistant quite simple
but hopefully fun for you
from scratch and the main idea of this
assistant is that is going to be a
chatbot that is good there is going to
be able to suggest interesting research
papers for people to read so for example
if you ask I want to read the paper
about statistics or something like that
and the system will be able to give
suggestions and then handle some
follow-up questions so simple but it's
just to show you how it all works so
it's going to be again in parts I will
cover the step by step and the first
part that I'm going to start with is
some configuration so it's not really
rather related but I'm going to use
logging to see where things go wrong and
to easy to debug my code easier if I
make typos which might happen also I am
turning off some of the warnings because
some libraries for example SK learn is
throwing way too many warnings sometimes
so I just wanted to keep things clean
and this little pretty print function
again it's not really rather related but
it's just going to print out JSON output
in our nice formats for us to see the
results easier okay so the next step is
actually installation so for this
workshop I'm going to use only basically
it's about three libraries rather core
rasa Nou and SK learn
CRF suit I'm using specific versions of
rasa core and Nou because it's still
kind of under development and the new
features are being added to R as a core
specifically quite often so I just
wanted to make sure that everything
works for everyone and before I move on
I will just check if that's actually
what I wanted to get yep so 1 2013 point
6 and core 1111 that's exactly what I
have okay and another thing which I know
already it cost people some issue
is a gravis it's a quite stubborn
library to use especially if you have
Windows user so I know that some people
also have to make some changes to their
environmental variables or paths on
their system to make the spark so if you
get errors at this stage just please
don't feel frustrated it's not mandatory
again a for as a but it just helps to
visualize data in a nice way so if you
get errors just yeah just skip the step
and I will show you the output as it
should look like okay so now let's
actually get to the Anna Lou part so
since it's based on machine learning the
first stage where you should start your
child development when you use rosin Lu
is conversational data now it's actually
one of the trickiest parts when it comes
to child development because
conversational data is really hard to
find and it's not something that you
would probably find on the web
especially when it comes to research
paper search you wouldn't find those
type of dialogues anywhere so there are
few suggestions that I would give you
how to get started if you cannot find
any data anywhere or any clues how the
conversations could go so one way is to
play a little game and pretend that you
are about yourself and just ask your
friends or colleagues to ask your
questions and just try answering them as
you were about write down those
conversations and and then use them as
the basis for your models simple and and
quite fun fun way but it actually is
quite a good good starting point another
one is
called interactive learning in mazik or
I will show you at the end of the
workshop how it works but it also one of
the good ways to start generating some
training data but I used the first
approach before this workshop and I
actually wrote down some conversations
myself so I have two possible
conversations here so as you can see the
conversation will start with hello and a
system would ask how can i how can it
help and then a user could ask for
papers about mathematics or anything
else and an assistant would actually go
and look for a paper to suggest and then
everyone is happy another possible
conversation when a user asks for
research paper but don't tell exactly
what type of paper they interested in so
an assistant asks for this detail to
make the search more specific and then
also a user asks for some follow-up
questions so for example who are the
authors of the paper and and so on yeah
so if you also start your own assistant
in your own specific field from scratch
the goal is to gather some conversations
that cover different terms of the
dialogue because again it's machine
learning so the data has to generalize
help your model to generalize well so
the one thing that you have to do once
you have some conversational data is to
convert it into the rasa format and this
process of format for a know you data
consists of labels of the intents that
you would like your assistant to
understand and possible examples of how
a user would say those specific things
so I'm just going to show you a quick
example of how this data would look like
and I will use this conversation number
two to actually go through the
conversation line by line and I'm going
to convert it into the rasa format so
the conversation started with the user
saying hi
so the overall intention of this input
is
user says hi so here I'm going to create
a new intent intent and I have to
provide the label of this intent so it's
going to be create in this example and
and then I will just come to provide the
actual example how the user will say
that so it was hi so Chabot responded
hey paper search assistant and then a
user said I'm looking for interesting
papers to read so it's not greeting it's
something else this is a paper search so
that's why I would create a new intent
which I will call paper search and began
simply the example goes in I am looking
for interesting papers to eat ok an
assistant asked what type of papers are
you looking for and the user said about
physics now this is not greeting and
it's not really a paper search because
it's just user providing some additional
information so it can't really go into
great intent it can really go to paper
search intent so I'm going to create a
new intent again which I will call
inform because it's just providing some
additional information and I will
provide the example which I can type now
important thing here is that we also
have to label entities so that the model
would learn to extract those as well not
only intense so physics is a good type
of entity in my case because it's the
type of paper and it's a important and
useful detail that will help an
assistant to make more specific search
api call a little disclaimer to
to actually suggest something in a
physics field so to label entities what
I have to do is I have to add square
brackets around the actual value of the
entity and then in the parentheses type
in the label of this entity so since
it's paper type I will just call it that
way
paper type oh yeah sorry
yeah just yeah so then an assistant will
go and look for a paper and then asked
if a user would would like to get a link
to the specific paper and a user said
sure you can also tell me who are the
authors of this paper now this is a
tricky one because as you probably see
there are those two intentions and one
input user wants to get a link to the
paper but they also want to get the list
of the authors who wrote the paper so
again we can't really put this into any
of the intense we have already so I'm
going to go ahead and create a new
intent and here since this is a compound
a user input I will have to write down
the label of the intent that consists of
tokens of those multi intent so one
meaning of this user input sure can you
also tell me who are the authors of this
paper is just confirming that a user
wants to get a link or affirming that
the user wants to get a link so that's
I'm going to type in this is the first
meaning of the user input and another
one is asking about the authors of the
paper so that's why I will add plus and
write down the label of the second token
of a user input which I will call
authors so that may
that this user input will have two
meanings affirming and also asking who
are the authors of the paper and then
again just like with every other example
here I would just simply provide the
example if in other case a user would
just say I think I actually have an
example in a previous conversation when
an assistance suggests here I can send
you a link if you would like to get one
a user said yes please
then this type of intent would not be
able to be added here because it's not a
multi invent it would have to create a
new intent called affirm but both of
these I can actually do that in turned a
farm would be something like yes please
and then when the model trains this
intent would be used to train that token
a foreign as well as this one would be
used to train that token affirm and
that's how the model would know when to
use two labels for user input when to
use one and so on
yeah and then user said things so that
would be another intent for example old
things since it's it's thanks Oh
yeah and then you were just simply oh
yeah and then you simply would provide
the possible ways of saying I think
thanks and so on so that how it looks
like but again this is just a very tiny
example of training data way too small
to actually build something that would
work so you would need at least I would
say for a simple child that is capable
of handling one or two actions I would
suggest having at least I don't know
five to ten possible ways of how a user
could take treat how a user would look
for papers and and and so on and this is
where I'm going to use one of those
files that I mentioned that I have in my
rep oh it's which is going to be a
little cheat and that's it's an example
example file of more training examples
I'm going to put them in here you can do
so as well if you're following me so
basically again just as I said it's just
a little bit more possible ways from how
to say goodbye of how to say hi of how
to affirm and so on
who are they can you tell me who are the
others
no no it's not again it's not really
very exist not really matching it it
uses features that I extracted from text
so those features can be
angra mess of words it can be or
surrounding words if it's about entities
so yeah it's not it's not matching at
all and again another important thing is
that you don't have to write all the
possible ways of how to say no or how to
say hello or something like that because
again it's machine learning so with
enough examples the model will start to
generalize and it will learn how to
classify a user inputs correctly and how
to extract entities as well
so again you don't have to write all the
possible papers and that you can read
out there that's the main idea behind
machine learning that you don't have to
cover everything but a little bit for a
model to learn so I'm running the cell
here just to simply save this data file
that I now created and then once you
have training data which is the biggest
and the most important part of every
machine learning problem you can
actually go ahead and define the model
and in razza NLU you can define the
model by creating the configuration of
the pipeline and the pipeline simply
defines how features are going to be
extracted from those examples that you
have in your training data also what
models are going to be used and so on so
if you are not familiar with machine
learning for NLP and you are now
thinking like oh it's it's too too much
to understand there are some pre-built
pipelines that doesn't require you to
know everything and understand
everything that there is going under the
hood but if you are you can again have a
lot of fun with customizing pipeline and
adding new components or removing so the
one that I'm using today here is one of
them is a tokenizer so how I
the sentences are going to be parsed
into words here I'm going to use simply
a white space so whenever there is a
white space between the words the model
will know that it's the word but it's a
new word or that the word ended this
nerve
ERF defines the conditional random field
model that i mentioned previously is
going to be used for entity extraction
then this one which is called classifier
tense for embedding so this is a
classifier for intent so that with the
one in terms of embedding model that I
mentioned previously that doesn't use
any pretend world vectors and the since
we are having some multi intense it's
important to tell that to our model so
by setting in ten tokens tokenization
flag to true I'm letting my model know
that whenever it sees an example like
this one here a forum + authors that
means that there are actually two tokens
for this entity and that they should be
separated and trained each each of those
tokens should be trained and also you
have to specify what symbol what
character was used to when creating
those multi intense substance I use the
+ I'm using a plus here if you used I
don't know - or something it would be
here included so you define the pipeline
I'm going to run the cell here so again
is going to simply just write this in
our config dot llamo file and once you
have that you are all good to go ahead
and free in the model so here I'm
actually going to do so so first of all
I'm going to load all these amazing
files that I created so at the tree to
load the training data I've of simply
call load data and the file was called
and Aleut MD so you can see it's it
works in a similar way as if you for
example used SK learn to build a machine
learning model and train you pass all
files first so then you can create the
trainer which which will define the
model so trainer will use a
configuration file so I think it's just
dot don't think load and I will load the
configuration file because it defines
the model so config dot llamo and once
all these things aren't ready I can
actually train the model by calling
trainer method train self-explanatory
and here I'm going to simply pass their
training data in and since I want to see
the output of the model what is
happening how it deforms I will also set
verbose to true which will simply print
the training results and the last thing
is I can save the model somewhere on my
machine so I will just simply call
interpreter because that's how my model
will be saved and I will call a method
called persist and here I can just
simply define where the model will be
saved after the training so I will
create the directory called models and I
would save it in a new model directory
and I can also set the fixed model name
and that helps because if you want to
make improvements and if you want to
retrain the model is going to be saved
and exactly the same directory and
exactly the same name if you wouldn't
then every single time you run this
function here rather
and all you would generate a new model
name with date and timestamp for you to
know when it was trained
so I will set fixed model name which I
will call current okay let's try and see
what happens okay so you can see already
what is it there are the summary of all
the intents you had in your training
data and this and so on and then every
single component that was included in
the pipeline is trained one after
another so you can see it used tokenizer
rice paste and conditional random field
then the classifier and why it failed Oh
should the trainer yes sorry yeah so
hopefully it's not going to take long
yeah so and you can see it trains the
model and also since it's a very tiny
little model you can also get some not
too much but some results of the
trainings what is the loss what is the
accuracy and then once the model is
trained is being saved in the director
way is specified so the model was
trained great time to actually test it
and see how it performs
there are two ways how we can do that
one of them is just simply tested on
user inputs so here I am going to use
this pretty print function that I
defined at the very beginning and I will
here I will call interpreter
parce method and here I just can simply
type in what a user could say so let's
try with very simple and safe option
hello and here you can see the results
of the NLU model so what it gives the
first thing is here which is the most
probable intent that was assigned to
this user input here you can see the
name of this intent post read you can
also get the confidence how confident
your model was to make this prediction
also you can get the list of entities
that we extracted but since hello
message doesn't have any entities the
model didn't find any and then
everything else that is here are the
results of internal classification for
all the other indents in the training
data and also you can see how confident
the model was to make those predictions
I will try it for another one where I
can actually show you how ended
extraction looks like so I will use this
paper search so I will say I would like
her to read a paper about let's say
machine learning let's see if that works
ok so one thing is that it's not really
informed so this is where the model
actually made a mistake it should have
predicted probably paper search but
again it happened because I have a very
tiny amount of training data but the
good thing that happened here is that we
have an entity machine learning which is
actually a type of paper that you could
look for and as you can see it extracted
the value of this entity it assigned the
entity label which is paper type also
you get the confidence level and also
the start and end
just simply corresponds to where in a
sentence this entity is okay so that is
one of the ways to test your model again
you can spend more time playing around
with this but another way is to actually
run some evaluation and resolutions with
some evaluation scripts that you can run
so result of this evaluation here and
it's going to be a confusion matrix for
all intents that you have in your
training data and how confident how good
your model was in predicting those on
the test data set and again it's super
tiny with training data that are used so
I'm pretty sure my model all fitted
quite heavily because you can see how
perfect it is right here I can see one
mistake here actually which is good they
should do more probably so greet is was
confused with goodbye once kind of makes
sense because they agree time goodbye
the examples of those interns have
usually just one word like hi or goodbye
so maybe it was a bit too confusing for
the model to learn but that would
improve if you would add more possible
examples and then you can get as well
internal prediction confidence
distribution which doesn't look very
nice
for some reason here but basically it
also gives you more information of how
good your model was how confident the
model wasn't making predictions and and
so if you see a lot of mistakes that
your model does the first thing that a
developer should do is to go back to the
training data after the training
examples and see if there is anything in
the intense how intense are defined what
kind of examples are being provided and
maybe something actually adds more noise
to the model rather than actually making
it better
so how question
Stephanie I should request morning
definitely you have to enumerate
enumerate all the possible combinations
of labels you know training set to meet
up with the natural language dialogues
it's I can't imagine for example a firm
that label can get matched with all the
other labels because I can take ok
goodbye
ok I want to search for another paper or
something yeah
yeah but that's that's the main idea
behind using real conversational data so
whenever you get a conversation that had
something new you would reuse that
conversation and you would add the
stereo training data and the main
advantage behind
for example rule-based approach when we
are talking about dialogue management is
that if you used rules a developer would
have to go through the entire
architecture of the system and find
where this new rule would be added well
in this type of approach you would
simply add this conversation into the
training data as well as Nou and retrain
the model and that would pick up but
yeah you would have to add combinations
if there are more combinations that you
would like to cover your model
because you will have a rank and you
will select but you don't need to do the
combination labels but you have all the
individual labels and have for example
all the contents confidential level over
80% again those two or those multiple
like labels are being matched with that
circumstance
every doctor yeah well it kind of works
under the hood in a very similar way
because when you when you have multi
intent and you have a single intent
especially when you have multi intent
the tokens of the smart intent are
separated and each of them are being
trained separately but still for the
model to learn that there are two
meanings for one at least for now and at
least how it works as browser would
still have to include them combined in
in a in your training data example but
that's interesting so maybe it's going
to be something for the future to look
into cool yeah
if so many different people with so many
different ways of saying hi yeah so one
thing is that we don't really build chat
bots for companies we just provide
software but based on use cases that I
see developers have yeah it really
depends on how many intents you would
have how many entities how many actions
so the more you have of course the more
training data you need but for a big use
case and something that runs in
production you will definitely need at
least a hundred or even more example for
each intent but then but then again the
main idea and it's one of the tips that
I was about to share at the very end is
that the idea is that you build
something simple you give people an
access to your application people can
start talking to it and then you capture
all conversations and then we use them
so it's really not scape scalable
approach at all for a developer to
generate hundreds and hundreds of user
inputs it's really really bad approach I
have some bad experience with myself
yeah
[Music]
I don't understand back yeah so the way
it works is that you actually can use
those confidences that for example
Andalou model produces the same is for a
browser core model and then you can
actually set the threshold so if if the
prediction is below something like zero
point I don't know 2 or 1 then a child
should always say something or do
something or hand over to a human so
that's it
yeah yes mm-hmm
so I'll actually I don't mention this so
if you go preach involve vector way then
you are limited to those languages that
have written more vectors so for example
Spacey they have language models for
English for aperture German Italian
French so basically it's a variety of
languages but if you for example my
native language is Lithuanian and now
there are some preaching verb word
vectors with fast text but before that
there were no preaching world vectors so
this is what you would use this pipeline
fold and model called word embedding
because since it doesn't use any
prettier more vectors you can use it for
any language that can be tokenized
so basically it's language agnostic and
you can build shabbat in any language
yeah my question back
so speaking of synonyms you can actually
include that in your model and you can
also provide possible ways of for
example if you have an entity in New
York you can have in New York City you
can have and why and the model will also
learn that if it's something one of
those few possible ways of how a person
could say the specific name of the city
then it would still extract this as an
entity city or location yeah
type of parameters of anything
so for test sets so it works exactly the
same as in any other machine learning
problem it would have some help out data
and run predictions on that and then see
how good or bad the predictions were in
terms of parameter tuning so you can
definitely change epochs how many ebooks
were trained why used to train the model
you can also play around with different
features so for example as I mentioned
in some some times and grams or other
specific text features are being
included so you can also play around
with what helps to improve your model
what not yeah exactly
okay can I actually I'm a bit short on
time and I will move on to the next
stage of dialogue management and then I
will definitely answer a question after
it if that's okay
so please remember your question so okay
the next stages dialogue management so a
tablet can understand what the user
means and now it's important to enable
your assistant to respond and respond
well
so again browser core and why would you
use razo core so as I mentioned already
state machines and rule-based approaches
they actually really great approaches to
start prototyping something build
something simple but the challenge comes
when you want to build something in
production and when things go big this
is where I have some experience as well
or building troubles in production it
really gets quite quickly to the stage
where you as a developer spend way more
time going through the architecture of
your assistant trying to debug the rules
instead of actually improving our
assistants so machine learning it takes
a completely different approach than
defining the rules and expecting your
users to follow those rules but machine
learning you gather conversations and
then you model them to approximate to
those conversations reinforcement
learning is actually a really good
approach when it comes to dialogues and
I think this is where it gets it's going
to get in the future however it's
especially in NLP related problems it's
a really difficult task still because
it's really hard to define good to word
function also you need a lot of training
data and people want to give it to build
something quickly and with logic or you
can build something simple and as I
mentioned give out to the users quite
quickly with very relatively small
training data examples yeah so as I
mentioned the main idea is instead of
writing more rules and building huge
architects just like this and I think
this is the architecture of an assistant
built with a state machine that can
handle only just a few things well and
you can sell ready how big that is so
instead of writing more rules it's
probably better to actually see look at
how people talk to each other or talk to
a chatbot and and use that to model the
conversations so the health management
how it works
first the simple explanation so of
course a know you model plays important
part because it gives the meaning of
what the user meant so intents and
entities are being used in the model and
they are combined with the current state
of the conversation what what the user
basically asked and also previous
actions so the history of the
conversations also come into place and
all of this is being used to predict the
next action what type of models you can
use you have a selection a simple
approach SVM but it's probably not going
to use the history of the conversations
what is being implemented in browser by
default is
recurrent neural network this is going
to use what happened now what happened
beforehand and use that to make
predictions
so once the next action is predicted
again it the status updated also an
assistant gives the response back to the
user and the cycle repeats whenever a
user responds again saying something
this is combined with this new updated
state and used to make a prediction for
the next action so this is a simple
explanation now let's dig a little
deeper
so how it's how it looks even more under
the hood so again I know you model in
the classification and and that
extraction results are being used they
are being fed to recurrent neural
network and not only that but also if in
previous actions an assistant made some
API calls or extracted some important
details that should have effect on how
an assistant should respond in the next
stage those details are also being used
and another thing is that if you do
actually want to add some rules or
business logic to how your assistant
response you can do that by adding
action masks so what it does it simply
limits possible actions that can be
predicted by an assistant at specific
stage on the conversations so if you do
that and of course to follow the rules
of probability theory you have to
renormalize them so that probabilities
that are predicted would sum to one and
then just like in a previous slide you
saw the action is being predicted and
their response is being made and passed
to the user and then again all these
details are being reused for the next
actions also this cycle here or
prediction cycle it it doesn't mean that
it has to repeat only once when the user
says something
so it doesn't have to be one user input
one childhood response it can be one
user input two or five actions from a
child's end so again it depends on what
kind of conversations you are going to
model using classical so let's go back
to the code and implement the dialogue
management model so again since it's
machine learning the starting point is
again data and this is why you would
reuse those conversations that your
users would have with an assistant
the only thing again that has to be done
is that these conversations have to be
converted into rasa format and this
format is called rasa stories a story is
an actual conversation between a user
and a bot the only difference is that
user inputs I have to be converted into
those intent labels and entity labels
while the responses of a Chatwood
has to be converted into action names so
I will quickly show an example how to do
so so let's say again I will able to use
the same conversation I had before so
the commercial converter conversation
started with a user said hi so the
intent of this input was greet so in
Razov story user input would start with
a star and I would just simply pass this
intent greet a child with responded with
hey I'm a paper search assistant how can
I help and this is a way I have to
assign action name to this response
probably a good one could be a trans
greet
then a user said I'm looking for
interesting papers to read so if I
remember correctly this intent was paper
search and then a child would asked what
type of papers are you interested in so
it could be a trends task type maybe and
then a user said about physics so again
the intent of this was informed and
since I have an entity here which should
have impact on what prediction of the
action should be made so I should
provide this as well when converting
into other stories so an entity was
called a thick paper type and I would
provide a value which here doesn't have
any difference what is going to matter
can't type anymore is if this entity is
provided or not in a user input and so
on so basically I'm again cutting this
short it's very important step so don't
cut when you develop BOTS but basically
we would go through a conversation like
that and convert user inputs into
intents and entities and responses into
action names and again the goal here
just like in an Illumina to get data
that is diverse that covers different
possible terms of the conversation
because again you want to build a model
that generalizes well so if you will
have even hundreds of thousands of
stories like that which will cover
basically the same conversation over and
over again the model was not going to be
good so we have to gather
diverse data or generate diverse data
enough when you just start developing
again I'm going to do this quick cheat I
I will use the file store is not empty
but has I think just about seven or
eight possible stories which represent
the possible conversations that I would
have with my assistant
so for example if I can show another one
that is different so this is super quick
one so a user said hey a child with
responded with high then a user asked
for statistics papers probably a child
would find one asked the figures would
like to read it as I said know that it
was a horrible suggestion and then a
child would got mad and said okay
goodbye so so basically yeah again you
have to cover at least few possible
turns in the conversation with those
stories so I'm going to just again run
the cell and save this data so the next
step once you have the data again the
most important step covered you have to
define the domain domain basically
defines the unit universe or environment
where the child will operate so it means
that a child should know what kind of
intense and entities it should expect to
get from the user so exactly the same
ones you define in your training data
and also what kind of actions it should
be ready to predict
so again just exactly the same once you
define in your stories using action
labels that you came up with and two
additional things that I haven't
mentioned yet one of them is called
slots slots work as placeholders for
important details that an assistant
should respond throughout the
conversation like from the very
beginning until the end or until a
specific point where you would like your
assistant to update specific value so
for example right here my child will
remember what kind of paper I asked
throughout the entire conversation also
when it will get some
there's about a recommendation it will
remember what's the link of the paper
that is found who wrote the paper and so
on so that when the user asks follow-up
questions the user wouldn't have to
remind again hey I asked about this
statistics paper can you also tell me
what is the author a child will remember
that by by itself and another piece here
is called templates so here is where you
can define how an assistant will respond
one specific actions are predicted as I
mentioned you have possible options here
this one is simple and quick you simply
can define how a user will respond if
you don't like this approach you can use
natural language generation to actually
build a model to generate those
responses for you but here basically I'm
defining that when action utterance
greet is predicted a child will respond
with hey on paper search assistant how
can I help if you want you can of course
define more than one possible way how a
child could respond so then it's going
to randomize a little and it's going to
be more engaging and interesting type
what you use okay so this is domain it
defines the universe where a child lives
and another thing that is not mandatory
but again if you want to build an
engaging chat bot you would probably
want to include some more complicated
action so I showed you how we can define
possible text responses how a user could
respond but in some cases you would like
to use those backend integrations so if
you want to and I do so as well because
I don't want my child would actually
literally look for a paper out in the
web and suggest me something and I would
like to implement an API call here so
those more complicated actions and rows
are called custom actions and a custom
action is
a class that's not just of two functions
first one is very simple which is called
name so it simply defines the name of
this custom action so that an assistant
would know what kind of label I should
be assigned to this to this action and
once this action paper search label is
going to be predicted a child will know
that it has to run everything that is
defined in this function run and this is
the body of this function and here you
write what the child should do at this
stage so what I'm going to do here I'm
just going to retrieve details from what
was the query from the user and use
those details to implement the API call
so first thing that I will do is I will
retrieve the paper type that the user
would ask and tracker in Roseau College
is responsible for keeping track of all
the slots that are being populated and
kept so I will call I get slot method so
and I will also retrieve the slot which
was paper type so that an assistant
would know what kind of paper it should
look like should look for and here is
just a very simple I'm just making a
request to look for a paper I'm using
here an API that is provided by one of
the German universities so it's
basically a really nice library of
scientific papers that you can play
around they have an API so I decided to
use this as an example here so I'm
simply using the paper type to get a
paper suggestion and I'm just simply
taking one of the suggestions
I'm also retrieving some details about
this paper so what is the title who are
the authors of the paper also the link
to the papers that I could pass it to
the user and the last stage here is to
simply pass them those details
to the user in a human language so I
will call dispatcher who which is
responsible in mazik or to dispatch the
messages back to the user so dispatcher
and it has a method called utter message
which sends messages back to the user
and here then I can define what kind of
message will be sent back to the user
again it's not mandatory if you have
some specific action which doesn't
really have a specific text response it
can be something else it can be a
picture that your system would send or a
video or which really depends on your
use case but here I will define a
message that will say I found a paper
hold and I will simply pass the paper
title just like that and the very last
line here is I'm simply setting the
slots for those details that were
returned after making this API call so
the title the author's the length so
that my child would remember those
details and again that a user wouldn't
have to remind a child but every single
time what kind of paper looked for okay
I guess it's fine if not I'll get some
errors but we will see and here I'm
going to use this quick graph this
example so one of the ways how you can
debug your stories and see if actually
it makes sense how your models going to
model them or not is to actually
visualize them let's see if that's going
to work for me okay
it did so what it does it simply
visualizes the path that is covered
by the stories you have in your training
data so for example here you can see
that conversations would start with
greet and then the flow of the
conversation would be divided in the two
possible paths paths one is when a user
immediately asks for paper search and
doesn't define what kind of type of
paper they are looking for another one
when the user immediately provides all
these details and so on and how it's
useful is that you can see what kind of
conversational turns are going to be
covered and again this is where a
developer can look into it and see if
maybe something is too complicated maybe
something can be removed and maybe
something is just again adding way more
noise into your model and how the
conversations are going to be modeled
then it actually helps so again if you
have more time to play around with this
definitely spend more time looking into
it but I will move on to the action be
training the bots so I will run the sell
here very similar process I'm loading
the the files that I defined it
previously which is my storage data for
training and domain I also define
policies so what kind of models are
going to be used for example Karis
policies this Alice TM model that
includes current state of the
conversation in previous states and here
you can also see just a very few hyper
parameters which you can soon play
around with so actually just one here
how many epochs you're going to use for
training but there is there are a lot
more of things you can customize and
change and test and then you can see the
architecture of the model that was being
used and also for each epoch what was
the loss what is the accuracy and so on
and inspect your model like that I'm not
going to spend too much time here but
again if you if you are developing your
body definitely it's something you would
look into in more detail but now I'm
actually going to show you how my bot
works because I spend quite
a long time building its own littie so
the one thing before I actually load the
model the agent and tested out I have to
define the server for custom actions
because in Roszak or custom actions were
run on a completely different server
than your bot and all the models that
helps in a way that you can make changes
to both separately and you don't have to
restart your assistant entire assistant
whenever you make a change to I don't
know API call or database connection or
something like that so since it needs to
run on a separate server I'm going to do
some jupiter magic i will actually have
a common line inside my jupiter and
start the action server just by running
this command which will start the server
and it registers the custom action that
i created which was called action paper
search now it's running it's it's ready
to run this custom action if it is
predicted and i can actually go ahead
and load my model and see if it's going
to talk to me so here important things
are just what i have to do is i have to
load my and all you model that I trained
previously I have to load the dialog
management model which I trained
previously and that's it
everything else here is just Jupiter
configurations to have this little chat
box inside my jupiter notebook so let's
see
what can they do for me so we'll start
the conversation with hello and my
childhood responded hey I'm paper search
assist and how can I help people see I'm
looking for papers about alcohol
childhoods
so I found a paper called response
selection with topic clues for retrieval
based chatbots Matt probably is about
rabbit and would you like to read this
paper and I can send you a link so I
will try to do this multi intent example
so I'll say yes can you also tell me who
are the authors let's see what happens
oh it worked I'm surprised because we
have a really small amount of data so
it's telling me a link I can actually
maybe try and open it to see if that
actually gave me what I asked
so yeah response selection for topic
Luce yeah so if you want to think there
is a PDF reader where you can actually
read the paper and it send me a list of
authors which is one poster okay so then
I will say thanks and and that's all
enjoy your reading so that is just one
example again please play around with it
break it fix it improve it and see how
that works I have just 15 minutes left
there is one more thing that I really
wanted to show you so I will skip this
part evaluation is exactly the same as
in NLU you can run evaluation script and
get confusion matrix for action
prediction but well I wanted to show you
which is actually my next step is I
don't weekly go back to my slides which
is closing the feedback loop so
something that I mentioned that an
assistant has to be able to learn from
user feedback additional details that a
user provides and this is what we call
interactive learning in Roseau core so
the way it works is that when an
assistant response to the user input if
a user sees that actually this response
was incorrect a user can tell this to
about you do the mistake and then a
chatbot picks up those details and
learns from it life basically
then it corrects itself and gives the
better response so quickly back to my
code so that's the very last step this
is not included in Google Club because
it needs to run on a CMD in a common
line so but it's included here so I will
just simply run this function here what
is going to do is going to quickly
retain my razor core model it's not
necessary if you want you can just
simply load your previously trained
model and it's going to launch the model
in a interactive learning session and
the interactive learning session means
that instead of immediately running the
predicted action a child will tell me
what it thinks it should respond with
also how it understood my input and then
ask if that's correct or not and then a
user or developer can provide the
feedback and improve the model so but
everything happens in a way that I
actually just talked about and just get
those outputs so I will start with the
similar conversation I'll say hello and
here an assistant says is the NLU
classification for Hello with the intent
we'd is correct so here I can already
tell if the intern classification was
correct or not so in this case it was
correct so I would say yes and then it
provides the chat history with as well
confidence levels for predictions and so
on and then it goes with the actions as
well so now the child wants to run a
trends grid is it correct or not so a
child wants to respond with hello
message back so thatís also seems like a
proper behavior for a child but when
someone says hello so that is correct
and and then I
but execute this action and then it it
keeps this information when updating the
model now because I'm a short of on time
I would just make up the situation when
the prediction is isn't correct so let's
say now my bot wants to run action
listen which means that it wants to look
and listen for next input from a user
and let's say it's not correct it is but
let's say it's not so then I would say
no that's not correct and then my
assistant it gives me the model gives me
all predicted actions with confidences
here it was super confident that it
actually should listen for the next user
input but if it was something else and
if I would would want to add this
functionality to my tablet and train
different conversation flow I could just
simply choose something else I don't
know say ask look for the author's and
so on and then it updates by its by
itself and then another good thing about
interactive learning is that it's a good
way as well to generate some training
data so when you talk to about in this
interactive learning session not only
the model is updated live but also you
can export the conversations you had
with an assistant already in horizon
format so this is where I mentioned that
is actually also a good way to get
started when you have no training data
simply to talk to your boat like this
teach new features add new new labels
intense entities and so on and
you can extract all this data just like
that you can export and save the data so
super quick you can definitely play more
around with it and also since the when
some new features added to rasa core if
you will try the latest version of a
soak or you will see there are some cool
visualizations that come with this one
and within this feature so give it a try
but right now I will actually go back to
my slides and I will just share some
final thoughts so the main idea is that
again it's important to not only collect
good data build the model that scales
that behaves well but also include the
user feedback and close the feedback
loop when a user can give feedback and
improve the model as as the conversation
goes however even though it might look
like ice easy you know you can just go
ahead and build all childhoods in the
world section NOP is far from being a
soft issue and there are so many
challenges and so many limitations yet
still out there and if you are
interested in this field there are just
a very few suggestions what you could
look into and work on so for example one
of them is combination of dialog models
so it's relatively easy I would say to
build a model that performs well in a
specific domain for example Hotel search
or restaurant search but the challenge
comes when you want to build a childhood
that can kind of do it all or do more
than one thing well so this is where I
rather also is working on research on
that and a lot and we released a paper
quite recently so hopefully the next
time I give a talk about it I will
share some news on that end and negation
is also really really big issue still
how do you train the model that
understands negation and and does it
well and rouser is constantly working on
improving the models and if you want to
can definitely contribute to that as
well because again it's open source so
these are just a take-home thoughts
apart from mentioning again that machine
learning is in production scales better
then rule-based approaches I also want
to mention that again it's not like
rule-based approaches of state machines
are like the worst and you should never
use them actually it does sometimes make
a lot a lot more sense to combine both
and use rules and some business logic
alongside a machine learning and it
actually works a lot better than just
always relying on machine learning only
it's really important to be mindful and
understand the problem you are dealing
with and what you want to build and and
build your solutions based on that and
to finish my contact details are here
can send me emails can can find me on
Twitter as well and again since Roz is
open-source and something that I focus
on as a developer advocate the process
we are building open-source community
around Raza we have really a nice bunch
of contributors over hundred
contributors now actually 150
interpreters who contributed code and
who does amazing job helping others to
get started with Raza and helping us to
push the limits of our software and the
field so if you are interested do check
out our community join it and let's work
on this exciting field together so thank
you
and now I think I have some few minutes
left to answer some questions please
feel free you had a question yes
yeah it's it's pretty easy so if you
remember when I showed that pipeline
when you configure the pipeline instead
of using the the label of the component
that is in built-in rasa
it would use your own reference to your
own model somewhere in a specific file
or somewhere else
yeah but again you can integrate them to
work together or you can yeah
not use something it's based on my own
experience working with Roz is probably
the library that I had the most fun with
when it comes to customization because
it's really easy to add new things to
remove something so yeah it's really
open to new things
anytime there's an error like these
people hold into that
yeah so again since Rizzo Corps comes
with hyper parameters that are set so
there is a default set of parameters you
can find them all in the code because
again everything is public and open
source you can look into what kind of
set of parameters it uses but also as I
showed it depends it really depends on
your problem the field the the domain
you are building your assistant and how
much data you have so this is where you
can see that if actually the default
values of hyper parameters are not
really working well you can actually
tune them yourself and set different
values of hyper parameters for for
entangle cific ation and entity
extraction since it uses SVM it also
runs grid search and it looks for best
hyper parameters every single time but
again it's something you can also change
depending on how you want the models to
behave yeah well it was no no again
everything is open source so you see
everything and there are default models
that are default values that based on
our research and testing performs best
but again you can see everything and
change
most a pretty stable even when you made
changes and when you make when you've
changed your trainings you know well
that is a parameter that is super easy
to tune and this is something that we
actually encourage people to think about
when depending on how much data they
have but it's it's more about like how
many layers are being used and in the
neural network and this is why we do
provide defaults that works very well on
majority of datasets that we tested but
again it's it's if it's something super
specific it might not work for your
specific case and you might want to look
into it and make changes
how organized the answer fashioned phone
somewhere probably Google results and
organized the answer as a natural
language expression and provides
feedback to the customer like if you get
a paper titled how all the nights it as
a sentence its
you guys
oh you mean how to have to use that to
generate training examples in a way yeah
yeah so again is something that really
depends on developer and and how they
want to build again because it's because
we don't build tablets for other
developers or companies but there are
some tools one of them is called chat
Ito which is quite popular so it's you
can for example do some web scraping and
fetch possible I don't know papers that
people might want to read and then you
can define that those specific entities
should be included and then you can
define the structure of the sentence
that you would like your training
examples to have and then it generates a
run with a randomization it generates a
lot of possible ways of how a user could
ask for different papers and so on and
other ways again just by just looking at
what kind of things people ask so
something way it's a little easier for
customer services and companies that
actually has some some data maybe not
specifically in a nice conversational
format but something that they can
actually take understand what kind of
things people would ask and then we use
those details
yeah it's a chatot oh so it's yeah let
me see if I can find
yeah this one
yeah noise
yeah okay I see one question there and
then yeah okay I'm going to have a true
heart sorry
one of the things you mentioned what a
new response was the challenge in coming
over 20 examples that you went through
you were essentially an annotated house
as you are given exact what's the bigger
scale sort lets me allow state machine
each a block that you're translating it
to something more natural we have a lot
of training data which need to be
annotated and the you guys have a
solution called energy for them can you
touch on Nikola the future gifts for
that in terms of you know multiple
people in the team behind it even good
now a second question are there key best
practices for actually deploying this
new production yeah so on a data point
of view yeah that's that's actually a
big thing when it comes to developing
something and especially run companies
as you mentioned have already a lot of
conversational data so I do see this in
a lot of companies becoming a future for
people to actually being hired for those
type of positions to actually go through
not necessarily only conversational data
but when it comes to any other machine
learning application to actually do data
annotation
yeah but right now the best approaches I
mentioned is to actually do annotation
for at least a subset and then give it
to the users and then reuse what is
produced by Raza as you talk to your bot
and for deployment part so based on what
we see when it comes to big companies
how they deploy is docker is probably
the best way to actually package it
easily and monitoring production because
also rather comes with docker images for
everything is it usually right now I go
to a solution when it comes to the point
yes
yeah interesting uh yeah it's it's also
one of those tough problems in NLP I
know some people working on on sarcasm
classification and identification but
it's basically a another model that you
would build I'm actually maybe can't
touch this on just in general how we
would add additional component for the
model so a really common request for
from developers is how do you add for
example sentiment analysis to your butt
or sarcasm eye identification and then
use the results of the model to adjust
your pot so you can also do that and you
would get either label and how sarcastic
it is or not but again it's it's an not
it's kind of falls into the Chabad field
but in over there you would build a
different model to extract features that
identify what this sarcasm what is not
yeah
any more questions
okay if not so then thank you very much
for coming and staying and I will be
here tomorrow so if you have more
questions or something that you would
like to talk about it also just catch me
I also have some cool browser sticker so
it's really worth speaking to me thank
you
[Applause]